all data store queries are performed
using indexes and knowing how they work
is important when you design and build
your applications if you have worked
with a relational database management
system and SQL you should be aware that
those indexes are not the same as
statist or indexes indexes in our DBMS
are a query optimization used to
retrieve your results faster while
indexes in data store are in fact
required to perform a query on that data
at all so if you want to query for data
store data there has to be an index for
that data be sure to remember this so
let's look at data store indexes by
going back to conferences and look at
what happens when we perform a search on
the property City in fact let's even
talk about what happens before the query
when storing entities data store also
updates index tables which are later
used to find entities when a query is
made these index tables consists of an
index value that maps to a matching
entity key taking the city Berlin as an
example the index value would be
constructed using the kind conference
then the property City and finally the
value of the property Berlin here are
the index values for the city's
Halloween London and Paris so again the
index value is a combination of the kind
property and value of the property each
index value then points to the entity
key where the value resides so a
matching entity where city is Berlin has
the following key and one with London
has the following key and so on so let's
say your favorite city is Paris and you
would like to get all conferences that
are in Paris then data store would look
at the index table where city is Paris
and find all matching entity keys since
data store require index tables to
perform queries every property that you
query for will need an index table by
default data store creates these
automatically but we will also see how
you can control this later on